[Inaudible] Oh, hold on. I've got it. We've got to speak English. Sure. Yeah.
The thing is that you understand Swedish and do you speak Swedish,
but you prefer English because he grew up in, in America. Um,
your, your father, if we saw him in the clip hair. Yeah.
He was a pioneer in commercial television. Uh, he changed the, the,
the sort of television world in Scandinavia and, and, uh,
among other things with TV tree. Uh,
and you are not often a guest on television? No, not at all. No. Uh,
but when you, when you were to come here as a guest,
what was your worst nightmare that could happen?
Well, first it's, uh, it's it's SVT, so you never know. No. Uh,
but I think,
I thought back to when a T3 first launched and my aunt who was foreign
minister, um,
went on television and she appeared with another mysterious guests that she
hadn't been warned about, which was someone who was a professional Forter.
So you can imagine the surprise when my very capable, very talented,
very serious aunt as foreign minister went on the brother's television station
with someone who I believe was 14, a song next to her.
And it gave him great joy. He media brought him a lot of joy,
um, but it is my worst nightmare.
So I've seen the guests in the green room and there were no such activities
going on backstage.
Um, but it wasn't the eighties. So the world was so different than the eighties.
Wasn't it? Uh, let's go back. Not that far, but go,
let's go back to, to 2002. Um,
your father passed away very suddenly. Yes. Uh,
and you were 24 years old and you were to take over this company.
Uh, can you,
can you describe that coming into that boardroom for the first time as head of
the company?
Well, it was not as apparent as that, that, that if I didn't try at least,
uh, and put myself forward, then somebody else inevitably would have, right.
So it wasn't so much an error parent as a, as it feels 14 years later. But,
um, it was a very tumultuous time.
It was very sad time for obviously me and for my family,
but in a way, um, we picked ourselves up as a group of, of, uh,
executives and a group of companies and we banded together and I think we have a
very, very strong, you know, culture.
So I felt supported even at that young age. And, um,
I think if I knew now what I kind of knew, then what I know now,
I probably wouldn't have tried, but, um, why, why is that?
Because I think businesses it's complex, you know,
there are lots of people that depend on you. Um,
we have 80,000 employees around the world in 80 countries and you have a
tremendous sense of, of duty and that moment to, to step in and try.
W were they ready for you? The rest of the board? I mean, it was,
this was came very sudden for them as well. It was a very different.
Yeah. And I think for that, I feel immense gratitude today. Um,
because I think that they signed up for a 59 year old entrepreneur,
uh, a man that, you know, two plots and the man that, uh,
was constantly thinking about what, what was lying ahead.
And instead they got a very young 24 year old me.
So I think the fact that they even stuck with the businesses, uh,
shows that the no one's bigger than the company. And, um,
and I'm very grateful for that.
In the midst of all this. W D how did you find the time to do,
to mourn your father?
It was difficult. I think Everett is a very individual thing, as you know,
and I think that, um, I was able to do that through, through the businesses,
to an extent it really felt,
and I think to a large extent is still like a family. Um, so there,
when you're an entrepreneurial group, like us,
people have worked for 25 years in some of these companies.
So I was able to live and, and be close to him and his legacy through,
through that business. It sounds funny, but it,
unless you're in a family business, it's a very particular feeling,
but I think going there and being with the people that he had spent so much time
building companies and creating value with was in a way cathartic, right.
It was not traditional. I wouldn't recommend it for people,
but I had years of that.
And eventually you get to it eventually you're able to mourn.
In what way would you say that you are different from him as a
person? I mean, uh, not only as a leader, but as a person.
Um, I would say that I'm a, I'm quite a sensitive person. Um, so I think that,
you know, I take things quite personally and I, you know,
want to do a very good job and I'm overly prepared and I worry about things.
I think my father gave an impression that, you know,
he was creating things for the first time. So when you're a pioneer,
you're not worrying about what other people do because it's so difficult.
Probably no one else is doing it. So I'm worried about,
I don't want to go first, but I don't want to be last.
I don't want to miss the train. And so I think, um,
I'm quite a sensitive person and he, he was that way as well,
but I think it was less apparent in business.
You like him, you, you are, um,
investing a lot of money in new technology and he was as well.
And the technology we had back then, uh, and, and, um,
just now we can,
we can see you in this project where one can sort of live through your eyes.
One can, one can be in your head and see things from your perspective, uh,
through technology. Uh, and,
and would you say that this technology is the next big thing?
This is about, um,
connecting connectivity and about agreeing to become an avatar,
uh, whereby for one hour, um, our customers and people who,
um,
log on can get inside my helmet and my head and see a day
in my life.
Is it, would you say that that is the future? Are you, are you in, uh,
involved in that kind of projects in the future?
So in, uh, in healthcare, for example,
one of the things that we've just invested in is about, uh, offering health,
both diagnosis and advice through the mobile phone, which was very much,
my father's big bet in life was mobile technology, uh, as you know,
up here in Sweden. Um, but it's to create,
give health advice through the creation of an avatar. Absolutely.
So Y Y Y health, is that,
is that also because of, I mean,
your personal story with your father passing away too early in life,
is that a part of the reason that you want to invest in health? You want to,
you want to go go.
I think after 14 years of business, uh,
you,
you have a choice to either become a little bit cynical or to reinvent yourself.
And so I think that what I realized with our company is that you have to,
you have to shape it and mold it into something that you really care about it.
You can't have it be your father's company or your, your grandfather's company,
uh, and really change like we have. And so to that extent,
I'd rather be investing in technology that enables education,
that enables, um, uh,
healthcare that democratizes the same way that mobile telephony did 20 years
ago. So it's natural. I think, to go into those areas, I love entertainment,
but you can't be in, in just the media, media business forever. I don't think.
You have, um, I mean, you,
what you have is a long backstory of this company and it's been a family
company, uh, and through,
through history that has been difficult. I mean,
it was difficult for your father taking over the company. Uh,
was it difficult for you as well? The fact that it was a family company and,
and, and you have siblings.
It's, um, it's never easy. I think there are,
there's a small group of people out there who hopefully we can support each
other, but that, that go into this family business with their eyes wide open.
Um, and I think that it is, it is tricky.
And, and you bought out the others.
There's still, yeah, I've got brothers and sisters and they're still, um,
shareholders, um, but, uh, but smaller than, than I am and, um,
they're active and in their way, I think they wanted to have creative freedom.
Just like, um, you would have probably if you were my brother. Yeah.
Does it, does it affect what kind of sister you are,
the fact that you are the boss of the company?
I think I can be a better sister, definitely. Uh, 14 years later.
I think that you, you can't do everything with, uh,
the same amount of priorities. And I had my own family, I had the business,
and so I hope now I can be,
I can be a great sister now that the business is stabilized. You could say.
Th th th the thing is that, that you you've when you took over,
and when you, when your father died, you,
there was one brother that you didn't know about. Uh,
how, how did you handle that?
It was, um, I think with time, you, uh,
you learn to accept all kinds of surprises. Right. But, um,
I think that we were very sure not to judge, you know, my father,
I think my father is entitled to his life.
And I think that we very quickly understood that it's above all. It's, it's sad,
you know, it's, it's very tragic for everybody to lose your father,
especially a father that you didn't know as well. Right. So I think that, um,
with time you become a lot more accepting of, of choices that your parents make.
But I think for, for us then it was just about, about doing the right thing,
right. About being fair and about, um, you know, moving forward.
Hmm. Do, do you know him? I don't know him that well now,
overall, I mean, you're five siblings then, uh,
which one of them have you been closest to?
It's all, I mean, you, the four of us grew up in, in one, in one household,
one family, um, and that if you have siblings knows,
it comes with its challenges and it's fun. Um, and, but my,
my youngest brother max, um,
I was close to cause he was involved as well in the business and he was very
much a big supporter of, of mine and of what we were trying to build.
So, so w was the plan that, I mean, he passed away last year. Yes, he did.
What was the plan that he was going to be a part of the business in the future
as well? Yeah. What kind of part did he play?
Well, I think from the very beginning, I think if you think he was only 16,
when his own father died,
I think it started with the expectations and the hope that he would be involved,
even from my father's point of view. Right. And so, um, he was,
he believed very much in, in the ability of technology to change people's lives,
to bring choice and to bring joy,
whether it's through e-commerce and selling a pair of jeans or whether it's
through education and healthcare. So he was our customer,
he was the generation with the confidence that he brought to,
to business to really have a, a dialogue with these entrepreneurs that,
that I deal with on a daily basis,
he was the perfect balance to my rather strict approach, to,
to try and to build value.
He became sick at a young age and, and this was, this was a surprise for you,
wasn't it? I thought he was started.
Diabetes and, um, I think type one diabetes, and it gets very serious,
which is why I'm quite involved in other things for children. Um,
both here at home in Sweden, as well as, as well as abroad, but, you know,
diabetes is increasingly becoming, um, you know, a big problem,
especially for young people who, who don't know how to treat it. So.
The thing is that through these years that you've been the chairman,
you have multiplied the value of the company. Um,
and then, so then I wonder,
why did you choose to step down because you, this earlier this year,
you announced that you will set down as a chairman.
You look like a disappointed shareholder, Frederick. How,
how disappointed were they? I'm not a shareholder. You looked all of us.
Suddenly like a little disappointed. No. Um, I, uh,
I think all things have it's it's time, right?
So I think when you're doing something from 24 years old to 39 years old,
um, I had, uh, uh, end of last year where I sat down and said, you know,
before I'm 40, um, I don't want to be carried out, uh, from the boardroom,
I'm an entrepreneur.
I want to go back to finding people who can bring ideas and energy to,
to what I believe in. So I stepped back from the formal role,
allowed a great person to do.
For me. Were there other reasons as well? Well,
what are you, what are you getting? Well, I'm getting, I guess,
one thing that surprised me a lot,
that this is funny because when I met you before, well, the thing is that I.
Like to surprise you sometimes too. Yeah.
But well you did. And in they come, no, I'm just bringing the fart back.
But the thing is that the thing is that, that when I,
when I met you before this interview yep. For our cow, for our little fecal.
Yes. You, you had a very young baby yes. With,
with you a little five week old. Yes. A five week.
You did very well holding him. Thank you very much. I'm,
I'm quite as experienced actually. And with that. Uh, but,
but the thing is, I didn't know, nobody knew, and this is your first son,
your fourth kid, but your first child. Yeah. Yeah. Um, and it's, uh,
it's really, uh, it was a secret in a way, but it then obviously.
No, I think if, you know,
if you're a shareholder and you see me in may and July, I mean,
there's a natural development around having a trial that becomes quite,
quite obvious. I think people are just polite maybe, but, um, no, the idea that,
yeah, just to, to prioritize some time for, for me, for my family,
I've got four kids under 10 years old. Yeah. So I think anyone who has,
has that knows that they have different demands and different, you know,
ways to spend your time. So that was part of it.
But then I think equally it was part of redefining my role. I mean, going to,
to try to do something different where I can add value in different ways.
I mean, Sydney, at the end of that board table, looking at a,
an oil painting of your grandfather and an oil painting of your father, you,
you might lose sight of what you're trying to do,
which is to go build exciting companies.
Do, do you still just sort of regarded as a family company?
Absolutely. But do you, I mean,
now that you have your own family yes. Uh, um, eh, quite many,
you are quite many. I mean, no.
Plus we pulled up in the parking lot.
Four children. That's, that's, that's a, that's a bunch more than average. Uh,
I mean, do you, um.
Do.
You also want to live a different life than you had as a, as a chairman?
Do you want to have, do you want to lead a different life?
Um, yes, definitely. How Crow, because I think it's,
I think you have the company and you have the,
the business and the legacy responsibility,
but you also want to be free to go and find new
opportunities to, I moved back to Sweden almost exactly a year ago. Um,
I want the kids to speak Swedish, to feel Swedish, to walk to school. Um,
so some of the simple things I think become very,
very important after the kind of 14 years that I've had. So yeah.
You moved back to Sweden. Yes. Your husband, Alex. He's still in England.
And he's here sometimes do he's coming tonight.
Okay. So he lives there or.
His business is abroad, but no, he's, he's back and forth. Yeah.
His business is.
It's sort of a event company, is it? Yes. Yes. And it's very big.
I don't buy it's it's he's he does very well. He works very, very hard.
It didn't he creates, uh, events.
Yeah. Th th th I think, eh, the Royal wedding, right.
He did which the one with Kate.
But if you don't
[inaudible] up the street. No, he doesn't. He's a great business.
He's a great entrepreneur. So yes, he is an event organizer all over the place.
Who is, is he in your life? I mean, not just the event organizer. Right.
Well, that meant the know that too. Yeah, he does organized, I must say no, but,
um, he's, he's been a very important part of, of, of course who I've become and,
and the choices that we make together for our family. So, yeah. He's great.
So is it involved? I mean, you, you, you, you discuss things.
Oh, was he? Yes. But I think I also,
might've tried to get him to think it was his idea a few years, but in the end,
when we decided to go [inaudible].
How do you prepare your kids for one day they might take over,
how can you prepare them?
They, um.
They might be in your situation. I mean, you know.
Yeah. I think I'll, I'll,
I'll make sure things are a little bit more orderly if I,
if I can choose a little bit fewer, fewer startup companies, uh, to,
to step into. But no, I think this part of being in Sweden,
part of being in Sweden is, is to, to, to show them that, you know, you're,
you're a part of this, this family,
and you're part of this business and you're part of this community that does
interesting things.
So I have one child here today and we'll see what she says about the media
business.
Thank you so much for being with us. Thank you.